ILANA BENISH: My name is Ilana
Benish, and I am 38 years old.
I was born blind.
I had many surgeries,
and they have succeeded
to improve my sight in one eye.
Independency means access.
Many of the technologies
that are available today
are not accessible.
And that's why I
came to APPlicable.
MICHAL WALTNER:
My name is Michal.
I'm the program manager
of Campus Tel Aviv, which
is a Google space that is
dedicated to entrepreneurs
and startups, meaning
helping the local ecosystem
to create amazing startups.
I started thinking, how is it
possible that this huge market
is not being addressed?
Because if they knew that,
with some easy steps,
they can actually make their app
accessible to this huge market,
I was sure that they'd bound
to do something about this.
So this is how the idea of this
problem of APPlicable started.
ARIEL KEDEM: My
name is Ariel Kedem.
I'm a mobile product
manager at Fiverr.
Fiverr is a marketplace
for creative professionals.
We are helping people
productize and make money
from their talent.
Fiverr is trying to
change how people work,
and allowing people
with disabilities
to work with Fiverr
is something big.
MICHAL WALTNER: So we
started with visually
impaired and blind people.
Each table had a startup.
Mentors from the design
world, from the product world,
and developers sat
together with a person
with a visual
impairment and a person
who's blind to see how he's
actually using his own app.
JONATHAN LEVIN: My name is
Jonathan, Android developer
and evangelist in Gett.
Gett is a leading platform
from on-demand services,
like Gett Taxi or Gett
Pizza, or even Gett Doctor.
I remember at the beginning
there was a woman who said, ah,
you're from Gett?
I'm not talking with you.
Like, you make my life awful.
When you make this difference
for them, first of all,
you feel proud because
you really helped someone.
One of the really
small changes that we
did that has huge impact was
that, when you open the app,
you have marketing pop-up
right straight on the screen.
And it doesn't have any label.
So for the blind people,
it was like, oh, we're
showing a regular map with an
address and an "Order a Taxi"
button.
And wasn't aware that they
actually had that marketing
pop-up, and they can't click on
anything or using the TalkBack.
And by just verifying that,
if the TalkBack is turned off,
not to show this pop-up
is, like, huge difference,
because now these people are
able to order the taxi instead
of constantly clicking
on the marketing pop-up
and not understanding why
you can't order a taxi.
Actually, the impact was that
she went out of the building
and she said, oh, now I
am able to order the taxi.
ARIEL KEDEM: We actually did
some really small change.
We have a page of
categories within Fiverr.
It was built, like, [INAUDIBLE]
category next to category
in a very long page.
And when we did
one of the session,
they just tell me, just build
them one in a row, and not one
next to each other.
So we changed it, we put
it in the app homepage,
and just changed dramatically
how people navigate the app.
Thinking about a
simple experience
just made me a better
product manager.
JONATHAN LEVIN: With a
really small effort, just
to change a little
bit bytes of code,
to add the additional
stuff, and you
can make really huge
difference for them,
for their daily routine.
ARIEL KEDEM: Tagging your
components on a specific page.
Giving an image
the right ALT tag.
It's really something that,
when you change how you think,
it's very simple.
Enable the accessible
view on your phone,
try to use the phone as someone,
just for example, can't see.
This will affect everything
you do dramatically.
- Button 96 unlabeled.
Button 13 unlabeled.
Button 74 unlabeled.
Button.
Button 18 unlabeled.
Button 35 unlabeled.
Button.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- How was it?
- Disaster.
Really a disaster.
MICHAL WALTNER: So
after about half a year
that we dealt with visual
impairment and blindness,
we went to the second
stage of the program
and addressed people
with motor disabilities.
So again, we opened
testing labs.
We brought the mentors,
we brought people
with disabilities,
we brought startups.
And we realized that
this is definitely
something that is so needed.
OHAD YIFRAH: Take your phone
in one hand, and start to run.
Run and try to send
message during the running.
You will have a lot
of mistakes, and you
need to erase and
retype, erase and retype.
And this is my life
when I'm using apps.
I am Ohad.
I am 39 years old.
I'm working in Gett as
a Senior QA Engineer.
I have cerebral palsy.
And the effect of that,
you can see my speech
is very-- I have a
difficult speech.
And my right hand
is not functional,
and also both two legs
are not functional.
And I have only one hand.
And even in that hand, in
three fingers I have a spastic.
It's very difficult to touch,
to reach all the corners
with one finger.
My wildest dream is that
I will have the ability
to put every each button
in the place that I want.
I know that the designers and
UI and UX wouldn't love that,
but it will make
the app park more
accessible for me, and for
the many, many other people.
This is my dream.
ILANA BENISH: To meet with
them to tell them our needs,
it was very, very
important meetings.
JONATHAN LEVIN: My
message to all developers
will be, hey, guys,
you are there.
You actually are
the one that can
have the power to change,
for a lot of people,
their entire life.
ARIEL KEDEM: I think about
this amazing APPlicable
session in every
screen, page, or button
that I am adding to the app.
OHAD YIFRAH: To make the app
more accessible, it's a must.
So now, the ball
is in your hands.
ILANA BENISH: Accessible
apps are changing our lives
every day, and will
continue to change
everybody's life, every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]